this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this is Frank Rossi for the Cornell
turfgrass video log and we're talking
about the black cutworm infestation
we're currently experiencing on putting
greens of course black cutworm typically
blows in on some storms and one of the
things we've learned about black cutworm
eggs with some research at the
University of Kentucky many years ago is
that they lay their eggs on the tips of
the leaf blades and by collecting the
clippings off the greens and then
removing them off site you can
significantly lower the population is
also really interesting research that
indicates how ants play a major role in
predating cutworm eggs now of course
once you get a cut worm problem and you
see what looks like little air fication
holes you'll also see sort of the
nibbling around the edge of the hole and
in the morning course you won't see them
very much and so you gotta you know sort
of look closely it can be mistaken for
ball marks and again or era fication
holes and so generally you know the
solution here is if unless it's severe
like the outbreak we have here generally
you can live with it maybe with some top
dressing or rolling if it gets severe
you actually may get some bird predation
and some more packing of the surface a
material such as a bio rational sort of
such as conserve should work well in
providing control on on that form of
caterpillar applied it's a really low
risk reduce risk material should work
really well of course there's a number
of other products that work well on
cutworm and also there are some
nematodes that will work on cut room
that we've had some success with over
the years as well so just keep in mind
start looking for them doing some
scouting check how severe the damage is
see if you can make your way out of it
with top dressing to smooth off the
surface collect the clippings get rid of
those eggs and if you have to intervene
a reduced risk product such as conserve
should be an ideal solution this is
Frank Rossi for the Cornell turfgrass
video log
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu